with that let's bring in Sheriff Brad
Koh from Queen County Texas which
borders Mexico Sheriff your thoughts on
this latest horrific example of human
smuggling that Ashley strommire just
detailed
right I mean it's unbelievable I've
never seen anything like this before in
my wife uh we're just completely overrun
and when we declared The Invasion I
think it's it's proven true that this is
an invasion we mentioned the tick tock
part of this Tick Tock was being used to
recruit drivers to take these
individuals across the border how much
longer is the Biden Administration going
to allow China which runs Tick Tock by
the way how much longer are they going
to allow China to destroy our country
one through the fentanyl they're
allowing across the border and now
through human trafficking
as long as as long as the current
Administration is in power they're going
to allow it it may be two years six
years however long it takes to get them
out but I think they will continue to
allow this there have now been more than
three million border encounters since
Joe Biden took off as border
apprehensions have more than doubled
since a year ago more than tripling the
number from 2020 but nevertheless it's
clear that secretary mayorkas is not
doing his job that DHS secretaries are
supposed to do the calls to impeach him
are growing louder but won't the next
Biden DHS secretary just rubber stamp
whatever this Administration wants
anyway meaning there's not really going
to be a change
the way things are going there won't be
a change even uh because part of the
Homeland Security's job is we have to
protect our borders but the
administration needs to listen to those
people in the field the border patrol
agents the ice agents as to what's going
on what they're seeing so they can take
appropriate measures they're not doing
that they're not listening to the chief
they're not listening to anybody
so what's Joe Biden doing he's not doing
anything with regard to the Border our
borders are completely open and said
he's lashing out after the court strikes
down DACA quote my Administration is
committing to defending dreamers against
attacks from Republican officials in
Texas and other states this challenge to
DACA is just another example of the
extreme agenda being pushed by Mega
Republican officials that's the left's
favorite word sheriff extreme how is it
extreme to enforce the law
it's not it's right there black and
white and forced to law policy should
not override law you know we're talking
about the DACA program uh we've got we
had one here in the county that we
picked her up two times
for being involved in Narcotics uh
distribution and Ice wouldn't take her
or couldn't take her because she was
part of that that dreamer program and
currently after we got through dealing
with her she went back home to to a
neighboring County and now she's in jail
for murder but we can't get rid of her
because she's part of that class I think
about that murder not like marijuana
offenses murder think about that for a
moment right so what does Nancy Pelosi
say she got on Twitter slam again Maggie
Republicans as well tweeting quote
shamefully extreme maggot Republicans in
the Senate have blocked this bill
playing political games with families
Futures while embracing again that word
again an extreme agenda of
anti-immigrant Cruelty uh look at these
numbers though I mean these numbers that
we keep going over that I mentioned
earlier aren't Democratic policies that
encourage people to make this deadly
Trek across the border really the
inhumanity here
the inhumanity is allowing these people
to die in the brush because of exposure
allowing these people to be run over by
the train because they're trying to get
from point A to point B uh we had one
last year not too long ago that uh one
of my deputies had to go out investigate
because he'd been run over by the train
that's not that's not being Humane being
Humane is setting up a program where
they can come in Legally if if they meet
the criteria but you said Nancy Pelosi
was talking about
the the extreme uh Republicans trying to
disrupt family lives what about the
family lives of the United States
citizens that are being disrupted for
these people coming in the ranchers the
the property owners Etc
what about their rights you took my last
question right out of my mouth so we'll
leave it there Sheriff Bradco thank you
very much great Insight have a great
weekend I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis